[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
sur fond de Guérande Ukraine l'hiver sur
le Vieux Continent s'annonce difficile
les dirigeants des 27 ne cessent de le
marteler depuis plusieurs semaines alors
que gastrom a totalement arrêté de
livrer du gaz à l'Europe via North
stream 1 pour échapper à des
rationnements en gaz mais aussi en
électricité Emmanuel Macron a appelé
hier les Français à la sobriété les
entreprises bien sûr mais aussi les
ménages le chef de l'État réclame une
réponse européenne aussi à la crise
actuelle il a pour ça notamment ouvert
la porte à une contribution
exceptionnelle de certaines entreprises
du secteur la solidarité européenne
sera-t-elle suffisante face à cette
crise alors que ces stocks de gaz sont
pleins pourquoi la France s'apprête à
importer de l'électricité allemande en
échange de ce gaz à quoi doivent
s'attendre à les particuliers cet hiver
sont-ils prêts à fournir les efforts
demandés on va en débattre avec nos
invités ce soir Olivier aper conseiller
au centre énergie et climat de Livry
membre de l'Académie des technologies au
soir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
avec moi également Céline Antonin
économiste à l'OFCE enseignante à
sciences Paris coauteur de le pouvoir de
la destruction créatrice aux éditions
Odile Jacob bonsoir également et puis
Patrick Martin geni enseignant à
Sciences Po spécialiste des questions
européennes bonsoir d'abord j'aimerais
qu'on écoute Emmanuel Macron le chef de
l'État qui s'exprimait hier lors d'une
conférence de presse après cette
entretenu avec le chancelier allemand
Olaf Scholtz
nous allons
finaliser dans les prochaines semaines
les connexions gazières nécessaires pour
pouvoir livrer du gaz à l'Allemagne s'il
y avait un besoin de solidarité et à
chaque fois qu'il y en aura besoin
d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui
pour la première fois depuis très
longtemps la France est exportatrice de
gaz vers l'Est de l'Europe de la même
manière l'Allemagne s'est engagé à une
solidarité électrique à l'égard de la
France et donc se mettra en situation de
produire davantage d'électricité et
surtout nous apporter dans les
situations de pique sa solidarité
électrique en la matière
on va tout de suite retrouver Luc André
notre correspondant Luc bonsoir est-ce
que l'Allemagne est en mesure
concrètement de fournir cette
électricité à la France comme l'a dit
Emmanuel Macron
alors sur les dernières années
l'Allemagne a été un très gros
exportateur d'électricité au premier
semestre 2022 l'Allemagne se classait au
deuxième rang européen derrière la Suède
la République fédérale a doublé ses
exportations en un an notamment à cause
de la demande française Bernard a déjà
livré 5 terawater jusqu'à fin août vers
l'Hexagone cela représente le double des
exportations moyennes sur toute une
année entre 2016 et 2020 historiquement
l'Allemagne était d'ailleurs plutôt
importatrice d'électricité nucléaire
française et ça s'est retourné alors il
faut mettre peut-être un petit bémol
assez assez bon chiffre les
gestionnaires du réseau électrique
allemand ont dévoilé hier trois
scénarios pour l'hiver à venir et dans
deux d'entre eux l'Allemagne manquera
elle-même de production électrique pour
couvrir ses propres besoins alors c'est
pour quelques heures mais mais tout de
même c'est un signal et dans les trois
autres dans les trois cas de figures
pardon l'Allemagne compte sur ces pays
voisins sur ses voisins pour l'aider à
stabiliser son réseau car le pays banque
de ligne nord-sud pour terminer la
grosse production éolienne vers les
industries gourmandes en électricité du
sud du pays et leur pour éviter les
engorgements on pratique ce qu'on
appelle le redispatch en lançant
notamment des centrales dans le sud du
pays où en apportant de l'électricité de
l'étranger et l'Allemagne a un accord
avec l'Autriche pour un cadre de ses
besoins spécifiques et pour le reste
elle compte sur la Suisse et sur la
France mais les gestionnaires ne sont
pas sûr que les capacités seront
disponibles au moment où l'Allemagne en
aura besoin l'Allemagne Luc qui dans ce
contexte prolonge de quelques mois deux
centrales nucléaires
alors plus exactement la sortie du
nucléaire était prévue au 31 décembre et
restait trois réacteurs en service un va
être arrêté et deux vont être mis en
réserve alors c'est ça veut dire que
dans le quotidien les deux centrales
nucléaires ne seront pas disponibles
pour produire de l'électricité et
jusqu'ici de cette année le nucléaire
représentait 6 % du bouquet énergétique
en Allemagne alors ça veut dire que ça
il y aura un petit peu moins de
production en Allemagne ce qui pourrait
un petit peu assombrir les perspectives
d'exportation les opérateurs de ces
instants nucléaires sont d'ailleurs un
petit peu
circonspects ils se demandent s'ils
c'est techniquement possible de mettre
deux centrales nucléaires en réserve
pour assurer la stabilité du réseau les
réacteurs nucléaires ont une certaine
inertie pour être lancée et pouvoir
arrêter en fait le ministre écologiste
de l'économie Robert tabac a pris une
décision de compromis politiques
l'hostilité au nucléaire fait partie de
l'ADN de sa formation politique et du
coup il essuie des critiques de tous les
côtés de Greenpeace qui déplorent report
de la sortie effective du nucléaire mais
aussi des parties qui plaidaient pour
laisser tourner les centrales afin
d'essayer de faire baisser les prix et
d'assurer
l'approvisionnement cet hiver parmi on
trouve les conservateurs dans
l'opposition mais aussi les libéraux qui
appartiennent à la coalition de la
scholls ces derniers dénoncent des
arrière-pensées électorales dans la
fermeture définitive d'une centrale dans
une région ou des élections ont lieu au
mois d'octobre et où la base locale des
Verts est intrinsèquement lié au
mouvement anti-nucléaire merci beaucoup
Luc André depuis Berlin
Martin Geny en faisant d'écouter Luc
André est-ce que cette solidarité
européenne évoquée par Emmanuel Macron
se gaz français en échange de
l'électricité allemande c'est une bonne
stratégie
c'est une bonne vie cela vient d'être
dit par votre correspondance sur le plan
technique c'est tout à fait possible on
a la possibilité de cette interconnexion
et je crois c'est surtout une exigence
politique on ne peut pas crier sur tous
les toits qu'on aime la solidarité
allemande si au moment les plus
difficiles ou une condition des moments
extrêmement périlleux pour
l'indépendance énergétique de l'Europe
la France ne vient pas au secours de
l'Allemagne et inversement donc c'est
très concrètement effectivement le fait
de pouvoir être solidaire dans des
moments difficiles je pense sur le plan
technique c'est tout à fait possible et
naturellement le président de la
République et le chancelier allemand ont
eu raison de dire qu'il fallait cette
solidarité je rappellerai que certains
états du sud de l'Europe tel que
l'Espagne le Portugal on voulait
beaucoup à l'Allemagne lorsque
l'Allemagne n'est pas voulu aider ces
pays lorsque ces pays étant difficulté
et il y a eu un débat en Espagne au
Portugal pour dire regardez l'Allemagne
était donneuse de leçon donc ce n'est
pas à nous de venir au secours de
l'Allemagne aujourd'hui le débat est
dépassé il y a eu un Conseil européen
des ministres de l'énergie et le
principe d'une solidarité européenne a
en effet été acté il revient maintenant
de l'appliquer très concrètement même si
effectivement comme cela était dit il
peut y avoir quelques difficultés
techniques au cours de cet hiver et puis
difficulté aussi peut-être des
populations à comprendre cette
solidarité Olivier apère c'est
surprenant quand même de demander de
l'électricité à l'Allemagne de la part
de la France
c'est surprenant dans la mesure où de
tout temps grâce au nucléaire la France
a été exportatrice nette de façon
importante c'était même le premier
exportateur d'électricité en Europe
malheureusement depuis un an le parc
nucléaire français a un certain nombre
de problèmes c'est ce qu'on appelle les
problèmes de corrosion sous contrainte
qui ont affecté environ que la moitié
aujourd'hui
la bonne nouvelle c'est que la solution
technique existe c'est que les
investissements sont en cours et donc il
y a un calendrier de remise en
production progressive de l'ensemble des
centrales qui ont été arrêtés
par exemple depuis la semaine dernière
la production de l'électricité nucléaire
a augmenté de 10%. donc il y a pas un
danger pour la sécurité
ça je fais confiance quand même à
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire pour y
veiller et
sur tes nucléaires Naimi aucune remarque
aucune objection c'est une Antonin la
France elle devrait produire cette année
moins d'électricité que l'année dernière
à cause justement de ces centrales qui
sont à l'arrêt une France qui produit
moins d'électricité ça va là aussi avoir
un impact encore sur les prix en Europe
oui forcément d'ailleurs on voit bien
que en fait tout ça tout ça est combiné
puisque le prix de l'ensemble des
énergies augmente des énergies fossiles
en tout cas on a le charbon le gaz
naturel et d'ailleurs c'est aussi une
des raisons de l'augmentation importante
des prix de l'électricité puisque
effectivement les centrales à gaz donc
qui dont le prix a fortement augmenté ça
se répercute sur le prix de
l'électricité effectivement donc tout ça
tout ça un coup et ça se ça se répercute
sur la France peut-être juste pour
rebondir sur ce que vous disiez au
niveau européen et le fait que on
échange avec notre voisin allemand il
faut rappeler que bon notamment en ce
qui concerne les infrastructures
énergétiques par exemple gazières on n'a
pas tout à fait les mêmes
infrastructures c'est à dire que
l'Allemagne c'est très dépendante de la
Russie et dépendant plus à ce point
beaucoup plus que la France en fait qui
elle a davantage disons de trajet de
gazoduc par exemple qui vont vers la
Méditerranée donc qui a des voies un
petit peu diversifiées l'Allemagne était
très dépendant de la Russie à tel point
qu'il y avait ce deuxième gazoduc North
stream 2 donc il y avait été envisagé à
la fin de l'année 2021 qui finalement
n'a pas été ouvert et mis en service
mais donc l'Allemagne a les mêmes
renforcé cette dépendance et en fait ça
a été donc une machine arrière mais donc
pour l'Allemagne finalement il faut
revenir de loin parce que elle s'était
construite sur notamment dans son modèle
économique ce gaz bon marché et donc
aujourd'hui effectivement elle peut
compter sur des flux dans l'autre sens
de son voisin français mais il faut
quand même rappeler que ce qui est un
peu compliqué c'est que c'est assez
compliqué de de retracer les les trajets
gaziers donc effectivement ça ne se fait
pas du jour au lendemain et Patrick
Martin geniet je l'évoquais mais
justement ça va être est-ce que ça va
pas être difficile de faire accepter ça
à la population française notamment de
dire voilà les stocks de gaz sont pleins
mais on va devoir aller en donner un peu
à nos voisins allemands je crois que les
populations les consommateurs ne vont
pas se plaindre si l'hiver se passe
correctement on sait d'ores et déjà que
nos réserves sont pratiquement pleines
elles ont été pleines avant que l'Europe
ne l'exige par ailleurs l'Europe et
chaque État doit présenter un plan
d'économie d'énergie à la Commission
européenne ce mois-ci on verra bien ce
qu'il en est donc effectivement on peut
craindre des réactions de la part de la
population mais surtout compte tenu de
l'augmentation du coût de l'énergie
regardez ce qui se passe au Royaume-Uni
qui n'est plus dans l'Union européenne
mais enfin on voit bien que il y a de
plus en plus un degré de soutenabilité
effectivement de l'augmentation des prix
qui est atteint il y a un problème mais
on voit bien que s'agissant de la
liberté il essaie d'instrumentaliser de
retourner les populations contre le
gouvernement mais je ne crois pas que
les gens seront contre cette solidarité
franco-allemande car ça peut jouer dans
les deux sens même si encore une fois on
a vu qu'il y avait des manifestations en
Allemagne il peut y en avoir donc en
France il y aura des difficultés si
effectivement nous n'avions pas assez de
stock d'énergie
[Musique]
sous l'influence de Berlin Emmanuel
Macron c'est aussi dit favorable hier à
ce que l'Union européenne impose une
contribution sur les opérateurs
énergétiques on va voir ça tout de suite
en détail avec nos confrères de France 2
on en reparle juste après
Emmanuel Macron et le chancelier
allemand Olaf scholls d'accord pour
mettre à contribution les géants de
l'énergie via une règle européenne dans
leur viseur les entreprises qui tirent
profit de la crise par exemple celle qui
vendent leur électricité au prix fort en
produisant à partir de charbon
d'éoliennes ou de nucléaires alors même
que ces énergies elles ne coûtent pas
plus cher qu'avant français Allemagne
voudrait donc les mettre à contribution
pour permettre aux États membres de
financer leur mesure contre l'inflation
pour ça il faudra convaincre les 27 ce
qui pourrait prendre du temps alors Olaf
scholse prévient si l'Europe
n'intervient pas l'Allemagne se servira
directement dans les bénéfices de ces
entreprises s'il existe des bénéfices
exceptionnels ça veut dire qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de milliards qu'on
peut rendre à nos citoyens voilà l'idée
en Europe d'autres pays ont choisi de
taxer ces super profits 25%
supplémentaires au Royaume-Uni
idem en Espagne où les banques sont
aussi concernées et en Italie ou
certaines sociétés ont saisi la justice
pour s'opposer à cette taxation je pense
en France le gouvernement préfère miser
sur la solidarité des entreprises en
attendant un éventuel mécanisme européen
je préfère que Total fasse des
ristournes au prix à la pompe je préfère
que Total fasse de la prime Macron pour
tous ces salariés plutôt que de les
taxer si total ne le fait pas ça déjà
été dit notamment par la première
ministre alors on mettra le travail sur
l'étalon contactez la commission
européenne confirme qu'une réflexion est
en cours pour mettre à contribution les
entreprises elle pourrait faire des
propositions en milieu de semaine
c'est line Antonin Emmanuel Macron il
fait attention il ne parle pas de taxes
mais finalement c'est une taxe sur les
super profits qui qui ne dit pas son nom
oui alors c'est vrai que pour l'instant
le mécanisme n'est pas du tout clair en
fait donc
alors c'est vrai que si on regarde ce
qui se passe un petit peu ailleurs on
voit qu'on Allemagne en fait l'idée
puisque là il y a eu un plan de soutien
qui a été proposé donc de 65 milliards
d'euros l'idée donc c'est une
contribution obligatoire des entreprises
qui produisent de l'électricité mais qui
ne produisent pas de l'électricité à
partir des sources dont le prix
augmenter parce qu'il faut rappeler
l'électricité on peut la produire à
partir de différentes sources or celle
qui a le plus fortement augmenté c'est
le gaz mais celle qui continue à
produire à partir de renouvelables et
autres elles n'ont pas vu leur prix
augmenter et donc elles engrangent des
profits et l'idée c'est de taxer en fait
ces entreprises en fait d'avoir une
contribution de ces entreprises à
l'électricité alors
enfin c'est c'est pas évident c'est pas
évident de transposer le modèle allemand
en France parce qu'en France il y a
aussi d'autres mécanismes qui existent
EDF donc par exemple qui a une partie
qui doit revendre une partie de son
électricité nucléaire aux entreprises du
secteur donc à un prix qui est fixe donc
en tout cas l'idée c'est de quand même
pouvoir taxer sans doute quelques
entreprises notamment la CMA CGM enfin
dans le transport maritime donc il y a
un certain nombre d'entreprises mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident mais
juste pour rebondir sur ce qu'on disait
dans votre sujet alors c'est vrai que
Total fait ce geste cette histoire pour
le consommateur il faut quand même
mentionner que cette histoire n'allait
quand même très inférieure au bénéfice
qui ont été engrangés donc c'est c'est
un geste un des bénéfices records avec
l'année dernière on était effectivement
sur 16 milliards de d'euros mais on est
quand même sur effectivement sur sur un
montant avec 20 centimes à la pompe qui
est inférieur au bénéfice finalement que
que fait total donc en tout cas c'est
une piste effectivement et on voit bien
que l'ensemble des pays européens enfin
en tout cas une partie des pays
européens s'y est mis donc je pense que
c'est Emmanuel Macron qui essaye de
passer Patrick Martin Genier par
l'Europe sur ce sujet
il paraît réticent quand même à mettre
en place sont-elles système
en France parce que ça fait aussi un
débat en Allemagne il peut y avoir des
tensions entre les libéraux les
sociaux-démocrates et les vers on le
voit bien parce que ça touche au cœur du
projet politique du gouvernement sur les
énergies renouvelables sur le nucléaire
et sur la fiscalité et on sait bien que
c'est vrai que la coalition en Allemagne
et Berlin s'est mise d'accord sur une
taxation qui pourrait rapporter de
l'ordre à 60 de 60 à 65 milliards
d'euros ce qui est important parce que
les ménages vont souffrir de
l'augmentation lorsqu'on dit qu'on va
demander des entreprises de redistribuer
c'est bien pour les ménages on sait très
bien que malgré cette solidarité
européenne et bien en Allemagne comme en
France les ménages vont souffrir de
l'augmentation du coût de l'énergie donc
il y a quelque chose un peu
immoral en quelque sorte de voir qui
puisse y avoir des super profits et donc
c'est l'idée effectivement que certains
qu'en France il existe le bouc
qu'il a effectivement un peu plus
réticent parce que en France l'État est
un peu plus interventionniste ceci dit
quand la commission dit qu'elle va
préparer des pistes ça prend un certain
temps parce que je rappelle que la
fiscalité au niveau de l'Union
européenne c'est quelque chose
extrêmement périlleux il faut souvent
que ce soit pris à l'unanimité on sait
déjà que des pays ne seront pas d'accord
pour prendre ses mesures de taxes
justement aujourd'hui il y a
urgent les décisions à Bruxelles en
général ça prend quelques années voire
quelques dizaines d'années le problème
de fond donc le président Macron a
abordé c'est la révision en profondeur
de la régulation électrique et gaziaire
la dérégulation qui a prévalu pendant 20
ans depuis 1995 en fait aujourd'hui se
révèle un échec et donc c'est une remise
en cause en profondeur il va falloir
passer l'hiver mais au-delà il faut que
très rapidement des décisions puissent
être prises et c'est au niveau européen
pour une remise en cause en profondeur
de la régulation électrique egaziaire
vers un système qui soit moins court
termiste alors sur les super profils les
super profits c'est un problème qui se
pose essentiellement en Allemagne car
les producteurs allemands qui ont
produit beaucoup d'électricité Aix
charbon limite en fait ils ont profité
ils ont vendu à des prix qui était de
500 600 900 euros le mégawattheure alors
que leur coût de production était de 30
ou 40 euros le mégawattheure c'est ce
qu'on appelle la rente infra marginale
et donc ça représente des sommes qui
sont tout à fait considérables alors
effectivement ils ont besoin de cet
argent en Allemagne parce que à
contrario leur importateur de gaz qui
s'appelle unitaire uniper est en
faillite et de façon très surprenante le
gouvernement a investi à nationaliser en
fait ce distributeur cette importateur
de gaz qui est un des plus grands
casiers européens mais qui est à la
faillite
ça ne risque pas de baisser leurs
production finalement et d'avoir une
conséquence sur les prix non alors à la
limite le Loris par exemple si on parle
de total c'est de dire ils peuvent
mettre leur
siège social dans un autre pays puisque
on sait que avec la libre la liberté
d'installation de l'Union européenne
donc c'est plutôt dans le sens puis il
faut quand même rappeler que par exemple
si on parle d'une entreprise comme Total
effectivement elle est taxée dans les
différents pays où elle produit de enfin
oui produisent par exemple du du extrait
du pétrole où il produisent de l'énergie
et c'est vrai qu'en France c'est une
activité essentiellement de distribution
ou les marges sont très comprimées une
activité de raffinage qu'il a aussi ne
va pas forcément toujours très bien donc
voilà donc il y a toutes ces
problématiques à prendre en compte et
c'est en ça que c'est c'est à mon avis
assez compliqué et chaque pays en plus
assez spécificités quand on compare par
exemple au Royaume-Uni c'est différent
parce qu'au Royaume-Uni on a la
problématique effectivement de
production de par exemple de production
de pétrole au Royaume-Uni que l'on n'a
pas en France donc chaque pays assez
spécificités on l'a dit sur
l'électricité sur l'Allemagne qui n'est
pas la même qu'en France parce que je
rappelle que effectivement comme je
disais EDF vend déjà une partie de son
électricité à un prix en fait qui est
très bas ce qui n'est pas le cas en
Allemagne donc voilà donc tout ça doit
être pris en compte et je pense que ça
prendra du temps c'est aujourd'hui un
vrai défi pour l'Europe il y a
d'ailleurs une réunion de crise des
cette ministre de l'énergie qui est
prévue vendredi qu'est-ce qu'on peut en
attendre concrètement écoutez on peut en
attendre comme on l'a vu pour le
règlement peut-être une position de
compromis une volonté politique mais on
est dans une telle situation d'urgence
que c'est extrêmement difficile de
prendre des décisions de conseil
européen et le Conseil des ministres ne
prend pas des décisions lorsqu'il sauf
lorsqu'il prend un règlement on l'a vu
le mois au début du mois un règlement
imposant des économies le Conseil des
ministres de l'énergie participe à un
système de libératif qui fait que on va
discuter sur tel ou telle proposition
directive donc je pense que dans un
premier temps il y a urgence que la
commission par sa présidente madame
monsieur lafontaline fasse des
propositions justement pour une
meilleure régularisseur régulation il
faut pas oublier que la Commission elle
est gardienne des traités et qui a quand
même cette liberté de circulation mais
la liberté d'entreprise donc on ne peut
pas imposer aux États un certain nombre
de choses notamment sur la fiscalité en
revanche il y aura sans doute une
position politique pour dire que les
ministres sont pour exceptionnellement
taxer les entreprises pour mieux
redistribuer et alléger la charge
fiscale la charge de la facture
énergétique des ménages la solution qui
doit passer donc par l'Europe mais pas
seulement c'est ce qu'a dit aussi
Emmanuel Macron le chef de l'État hier
soir il a appelé les particuliers et les
entreprises à la sobriété énergétique on
va écouter et puis on en reparle après
la meilleure énergie c'est celle qu'on
ne consomme pas mais notre objectif
c'est par ce biais-là en d'économiser
environ 10% de ce qu'on consomme
habituellement et c'est faisable par une
série de gestes simples en étant d'abord
dans une logique volontariste si je puis
dire et pas coercitif en appelant à la
responsabilité de chacun et en
partageant toutes les informations qui
sont les nôtres
on a on est déjà en train d'économiser
de l'énergie par rapport à nos
comportements habituels parce qu'elle
coûte un peu plus cher faut bien le dire
et parce que tout le monde est en train
d'intégrer cette nécessité mais si nous
nous mobilisons et c'est bien un plan de
mobilisation active auquel j'appelle
nous pouvons atteindre cet objectif de
10%
cet objectif
il est suffisant aujourd'hui pour se
passer de l'énergie russe
l'énergie le gaz russe
représentait de l'ordre de 17% avant
l'invasion
aujourd'hui ça a baissé environ 9%
10% bon c'est bien mais déjà ça va pas
être quand même véritablement facile
alors on parle de la baisse de
température la baisse de température de
1 degré alors à condition que dans le
pour le chauffage à condition que ce
soit systématisé ça permet une économie
de l'ordre de 7% aujourd'hui c'est
impossible de vérifier si les gens chez
eux vont baisser le chauffage donc mais
quand même il faut rappeler que donc si
on prend le cas de la France on a ce
bouclier tarifaire qui existe et donc
qui a plafonné à 4% l'augmentation de
des prix d'électricité et qui a gelé
l'augmentation des prix du gaz donc bon
c'est c'est vrai pour les tarifs
réglementés mais voilà disons qu'en gros
c'est ça le schéma on voit que sur le
pétrole on subventionne finalement on a
une baisse une ristourne qui s'opère à
la pompe donc globalement
c'est que c'est compliqué de changer les
comportements des consommateurs parce
que le meilleur moyen de les changer
c'est le prix justement c'est le signal
prix or on l'a on l'a quand même perdu
ce signal prix donc effectivement si
vous n'avez pas ce signal prix bah vous
n'êtes pas incité à modifier vos
habitudes de consommation c'est pas
juste un vœu pieux qui va faire que les
Français vont en même temps ça va coûter
tellement cher qu'on imagine que
beaucoup de Français vont essayer si
vous voulez les Français les plus
modestes si vous n'avez plus quand même
ce signal qui marche et en fait quelque
part on est dans une économie qui est
quand même subventionnée alors je dis
pas que c'est un mal parce
qu'effectivement vu l'explosion des prix
du gaz et autres il fallait sans doute
une solution de cette ampleur mais en
tout cas c'est compliqué avec juste des
vœux pieux de modifier les comportements
et effectivement en plus je pense que à
l'issue de deux années de covid les
Français on est peut-être un peu marre
aussi d'être un peu infantilisé donc
voilà je suis pas sûr que ça suffise à
modifier les comportements Patrick
Martin Genius
qui avait établant une prise de conscien
du vrai civisme parmi la population
c'est vrai que ça va être difficile pour
certains ménage en difficulté modestes
mais quand même lorsqu'on rencontre les
personnes on va essayer de réduire notre
consommation d'énergie prendre une
douche une fois tous les deux jours au
lieu de tous les jours diminuer la
facture de chauffage tout ça s'il y a un
esprit de civisme qui pense que qui me
fait penser que les Français sont
responsables globalement parce qu'ils
savent que derrière il y a des enjeux il
faut jamais oublier les enjeux aussi la
guerre c'est notre liberté c'est notre
indépendance donc il y a aussi un
objectif qui fait que les Français vont
être responsables maintenant sur le
bouclier tarifaire heureusement qu'il y
a ce bouclier tarifaire en France c'est
important c'est une spécificité de la
France c'est la spécificité cependant on
voit bien aujourd'hui que la Commission
européenne ou la Cour des comptes nous
dit que de toute façon attention ce
bouclier tarifaire ne pourra pas
continuer éternellement et que les
dettes ça se rembourse voilà
Olivier Albert je crois que le signal
prix effectivement c'est le Béaba et bon
on a bien vu que les nos
concitoyens
n'apprécient pas beaucoup le signal prix
rappelons-nous que c'est une ose de la
taxe de 6 centimes par litre sur les
carburants qui avaient déclenché le
mouvement des gilets jaunes
et
qui sont prévues samedi à cause
justement de l'inflation et puis la CGT
qui a dit qui a critiqué les propos
d'Emmanuel Macron Olivier Martinez non
Philippe Martinez pardon le secrétaire
général de la CGT qui a critiqué une
forme de déconnexion de la part du chef
de l'État
je suis quand même frappé du là j'ai
commencé ma carrière lors du premier
choc pétrolier il y avait une
mobilisation quand même forte il y avait
une mobilisation de l'ensemble de la
classe politique et une il y avait un
signal prix quand même qui était très
très clair souvenons-nous quand même de
la chasse au gaspilles enfin on découvre
en plus et on découvre aujourd'hui
que effectivement il faut se mobiliser
il faut faire preuve de sobriété alors
que je n'ai rien entendu quand même de
depuis le mois de juin alors qu'on
savait quand même déjà depuis le mois de
juin que la situation allait être quand
même extrêmement extrêmement difficile
moi mais la première ministre vous voyez
quand même des courriers au ministre
pour que les administrations puissent
faire des économies un tel courrier va
être envoyé au préfecture donc en tout
cas les administrations d'états vont
faire un gros effort en matière
d'économie
n'a pas été très mobilisée sur ces
thèmes et c'est vrai qu'on est en
vacances
estivale aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée on
revient
le signe qui me paraît quand même tout à
fait déplacé c'est la baisse
indifférenciée la taxe sur les
carburants et quand on regarde les
micro-trottoirs qui ont été faits à bah
c'est très bien on retrouve quand même
le prix des carburants d'il y a un an il
y a 2 ans donc maintenant la chose ça va
bien combien de temps ça va durer
comment est-ce que le quoiqu'il en coûte
moi j'allais dire ça il est pour le
covid là je crains malheureusement que
le réveil va être dur est-ce qu'on peut
concrètement éviter des rationnements ou
des coupures cet hiver si l'hiver est
froid
je crois qu'il faut distinguer en ce qui
concerne le gaz et en ce qui concerne le
pétrole en ce qui concerne le gaz couper
l'électricité
en ce qui concerne le gaz coupez le gaz
pour les particuliers c'est quand même
très compliqué parce qu'après pour le
remettre il faut qu'il y a des agents de
de GrDF qui reviennent donc on peut pas
l'imaginer par contre faut s'attendre à
des coupures de gaz pour les industriels
et d'ores et déjà vous avez vu cela
décision de Duralex qui a décidé de
d'arrêter sa production
donc ça veut dire que il faut s'attendre
à ce qu'il y ait un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui ferment provisoirement
ou qui ferment définitivement ça c'est
quand même c'est vrai pour un bon nombre
d'entreprises et pour le gaz en ce qui
concerne l'électricité d'ailleurs le
problème c'est les pointes les pointes
les extrêmes pointes qu'on aura pu avoir
du mal à passer alors effectivement on
peut y aller la maîtrise de la réduction
des consommations sinon il peut y avoir
des coupures mais alors il y a des
dispositifs qui existent d'effacement
pour les industriels que les industriels
s'engagent quand on leur demande à
réduire leur consommation et ça bien
entendu ça va être mobilisé pleinement
comme ça a été mobilisé le 4 avril
lorsque les prix ont atteint 2900 euros
le mégawattheure
mais si c'est pas suffisant et ce sera
peut-être pas suffisant à ce moment-là
il faudra faire appel à des coupures et
pour éviter ça aussi on pourrait passer
par exemple par le télétravail comme ça
a été le cas pendant la crise oui alors
c'est toujours une possibilité
effectivement mais bon enfin voilà c'est
ça un coup également dire moral pour
l'ensemble de la population de retourner
effectivement sur des injonctions à Télé
à télétravailler ce qu'il y a c'est que
alors sur le gaz en plus on a à peu près
moi j'avais calculé on doit avoir 60
jours avec les réserves de gaz de
consommation de gaz mais bon évidemment
on peut pas arrêter comme ça les flux de
gaz au sein des gazoducs il y a les
problématique de la vente aussi de ce
gaz à nos voisins qu'on a évoqué en
début d'émission je pense que c'est
effectivement l'industrie qui risque de
payer un lourd tribu alors bon
l'industrie certes c'est réduit un peu
de pays répercussions économiques
importantes oui tout à fait je veux dire
surtout dans une période où on voit bien
que l'économie c'est souffle et ou par
exemple pour revenir sur ce qu'on disait
sur le prix donc de pétrole et le prix
de l'essence on paye aussi aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus que le prix de du pétrole
on paye la baisse de l'euro face au
dollar et donc c'est quand même
essentiellement ça qui renchérit notre
facture et qui renchérit la facture des
particuliers donc c'est vrai que plus on
affaiblit aussi notre économie plus
l'euro décroche par rapport au dollar et
donc plus on importe aussi des biens qui
nous coûte cher et plus ça alimente
l'inflation parce qu'on a parlé de
l'inflation énergétique mais si on est
là on est dans un sujet aujourd'hui donc
l'énergie c'est aussi les engrais c'est
aussi donc ça se répercute sur les prix
agricoles et ça se répercute sur
également les services on l'a vu avec
les indices donc calcul l'INSEE sur les
biens man capturé donc sur d'autres
produits et ça risque de faire un peu
tâche d'huile alors nous en France on
bénéficie de ce bouclier tarifaire qui
nous permet d'avoir une inflation qui
est en moyenne deux points inférieurs à
celle de l'Allemagne par exemple mais
bon d'une part jusqu'à quand et malgré
tout voilà c'est sur en tout cas sur sur
l'énergie on voit bien que c'est pas ce
qu'on est subventionné et que la facture
quand même on est à plus d'un point de
PIB de de montant des mesures
énergétiques on pourra pas tenir
éternellement comme ça donc Martin moi
je crois que s'agissant du télétravail
les salariés ont énormément apprécié
ceux qui peuvent le faire notamment dans
le tertiaire beaucoup apprécié le
télétravail attaquement que beaucoup de
françaises de Français sont partis en
province et se disent c'est bien le
télétravail de quoi c'est une nouvelle
opportunité pour les salariés sur la
base du volontariat par exemple dans
certains administrations d'État on peut
télétravailler trois jours par semaine
et ce qui est tout à fait important
s'agissant d'éventuelles coupures
d'électricité il y aura effectivement
des industries certaines vont peut-être
fermé les collectivités territoriales
vont faire aussi un effort certaines
piscines municipales ne seront plus
ouvertes tous les jours donc tout le
monde va un effort pour cela et je crois
que ça permettra effectivement de faire
de passer l'hiver un premier hiver de
façon en tout cas au quotidien vous
l'avez évoqué cette crise énergétique
elle a déjà des conséquences très
concrètes des piscines ont fermé
brutalement leur porte dans l'Hexagone
et certaines stations de ski elles
pourraient ne pas ouvrir cet hiver à
cause aussi du coup de l'énergie
regardée
des cabines en mouvement mais pour
combien de temps un tir des stations
renouvelle en ce moment leur contrat
d'énergie mais les tarifs de
l'électricité donnent le vertige si bien
qu'à Villard-de-Lans le domaine skiable
pourrait ne pas ouvrir 50 euros le
meilleur Watt là aujourd'hui les
discussions on est à 800 euros du
mégawatt cette année on est passé de 350
000 à 450 000 euros et avec les All
Stars y faire ça ferait une facture qui
représenterait à peu près 2000000 et
demi d'euros aujourd'hui on est
incapable d'envisager une ouverture
puisqu'on sera incapable d'honorer notre
facture notre facture
sans les remonter mécaniques tout un
écosystème se réfragilisé magasin de
sport hôtellerie restauration une telle
fermeture c'est un manque de clients une
perte de 25 à 70% de leur chiffre
d'affaires qui que qui viendront chez
nous donc c'est là où il y a où il y a
danger pour moi ça serait répercuté
justement sur le nombre d'employés
directs des heures supplémentaires en
moi du chômage certainement ou même des
embauches qui se serait qui se feraient
pas du tout une des solutions serait
alors de faire preuve de plus de
sobriété énergétiques fermez les
remontées qui font doublon raccourcir
leurs horaires d'ouverture ou encore
leur vitesse nous continuons à
travailler vers une sobriété énergétique
beaucoup plus importante afin de
participer à l'effort collectif qui est
demandé de réduction aujourd'hui notre
objectif est d'ouvrir et non seul
objectif est de pouvoir travailler et de
faire vivre nos territoires un plan est
présenté aujourd'hui par les stations
devant la Ministre chargée du tourisme
les prix des forfaits risquent aussi
d'augmenter pour éviter que l'hiver
prochain
ne soit figé voilà pour ce nouvel
exemple concret Olivier appert tout ce
qu'on vient de voir ça montre encore une
fois qu'il faut investir dans de
nouvelles énergies aujourd'hui
il faut investir en fait dans des
nouvelles unités de production
d'électricité en particulier
des unités qui permettraient de
notamment de couvrir la pointe mais là
je reviens à ce que je disais sur
l'absence sur la remise en cause en
profondeur du système du système de
dérégulation il n'y a aucun signal de
long terme qui permet de justifier les
investissements tous les investissements
qui sont font actuellement dans le
secteur électrique se font hors de
marché hors du marché parce que le
marché qui donnait des prix de 40 euros
30 euros le mégawattheure aujourd'hui
c'est 800 euros mais aucun investisseur
de pouvoir prendre le risque de faire
des investissements qui sont lourds des
investissements de long terme dans ces
conditions résultat les énergies
renouvelables sont financées à coup de
subventions il y a des dispositions qui
sont prises de façon à maintenir les
désinstallations en fonctionnement même
si on ne les utilise pas et puis il y a
les Anglais nous ont montré l'exemple
pour investir dans le nucléaire ils ont
mis en place un système dit de CFD
c'est-à-dire une garantie de prix qui
permet de sécuriser l'investissement
pour le pour l'opérateur
Antonin il faut réinvestir dans le
nucléaire réinvestir davantage dans dans
des énergies renouvelables c'est quoi
aujourd'hui l'alternative disons que on
a quand même construit notre modèle
français justement au sortir des du choc
pétrolier des années 70 on l'a construit
sur l'idée d'indépendance énergétique de
la France et en fait on était bien
positionnés avec le nucléaire lorsqu'on
voit c'est qu'on paye aussi aujourd'hui
aussi malheureusement les haters moments
de la politique aussi qui ont fait que
un moment donné sous l'effet disons de
certains lobbies des écologistes et
autres on a voulu aller plutôt vers la
fin des centrales nucléaires en tout cas
la fermeture de certaines centrales
ensuite au contraire on a tenu le
discours inverse or c'est le genre
d'investissement qui demande vraiment
une vision à long terme et une vision
qui ne soit pas juste liée aux périodes
de crise donc je pense que
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
ça se construit ça se construit à long
terme on voit que par exemple
l'Allemagne a fait des choix aujourd'hui
que qu'elle regrette donc je pense que
en France avec le nucléaire on était
effectivement enfin bien bien positionné
c'est dommage d'avoir un peu perdu dans
ce domaine et donc moi je pense
qu'effectivement c'est ça l'avenir c'est
de miser sur je vois par exemple qu'en
Allemagne il y a vous avez des des
jeunes pousses qui investissent
justement sur du nucléaire avec zéro
déchet donc basé sur la fusion nucléaire
donc vous avez des jeunes entreprises
alors c'est pas pour tout de suite c'est
plutôt pour 2030 mais donc en France on
a
un savoir-faire dans cette dans cette
matière moi je dis exploitons-la d'auto
qu'en France on cherche quand même des
filières d'excellence on en a une qui
est toute trouvée avec Martin Genier on
a fait les mauvais choix côté je ne sais
pas si on a fait les mauvais choix parce
que on y sommes en démocratie
démocratie parlementaire il y a des
discussions des choix ont été faits que
l'Allemagne peut regretter malgré tout
je pense que ça ne met pas à long terme
le fait d'aller vers plus d'énergie
renouvelables je cite par exemple le
plan le pacte vert de la Commission
européenne maintenant c'est bien on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a une vraie réflexion
politique en Allemagne y compris ah et
ça fait des tiraillements au sein de la
coalition sur le nucléaire en disant on
arrête de fermer mais ça ne remet pas en
cause à long terme notre volonté
d'abandonner le nucléaire ceci dit il y
a une effectivement une réaction en
France le président de la République a
parlé de de réacteurs nucléaires à
relancer ou à reconstruire et même au
Japon lorsque vous regardez un peu plus
loin et bien regardez la relation du
Japon au nucléaire quand elle s'est
problématique et là ils ont décidé de
relancer de nouveaux nouvelles donc
en Allemagne ils ont décidé de sortir
totalement du nucléaire ils ont décidé
de relancer une nouvelle phase de
réacteur nucléaire encore bien plus sûr
parce que c'est le symbole de la
dépendance énergétique pour l'Europe
c'est à des principaux défis il y a deux
principaux défis pour l'Europe c'est
l'indépendance industrielle on a bien vu
pour le covid il va falloir rapatrier la
fabrication de certains médicaments en
Europe et également une indépendance
énergétique c'est un gros chantier
dans les crises absolument c'est ce que
disait Jean Monnet
bon moi sur la question par exemple de
rapatrier l'appareil industriel je crois
qu'on en est encore loin on a évoqué
effectivement ce débat au moment de la
covid on en est encore loin et on paye
aujourd'hui par exemple les problèmes de
transport et d'approvisionnement qui ont
aussi largement augmenté j'espère que
l'Europe va se construire dans les
crises mais quand même je suis frappé de
voir que la Hongrie décide est en train
de négocier avec gaz propre une
augmentation de ces achats de gaz
ça me semble quand même le consensus le
beau consensus
ce pays parce que c'est totalement
spécifique Victor Orban pour l'instant
et Or de l'Europe il joue le jour de le
jeu de Moscou oui mais c'est vrai que
étant donné l'exposition
comme à la Russie mais que ce soit pour
le gaz que ce soit pour le pétrole et
autres c'est difficile de trouver un
consensus unifié au sein de l'Europe
vous avez des pays les pays baltes
notamment qui sont très exposés là aussi
donc du coup ça rend difficile de parler
d'une seule voix et d'ailleurs l'Europe
de l'énergie on l'appelle depuis
longtemps de nos vœux mais on voit bien
quand on compare ne serait ce que la
France et l'Allemagne que les choix
énergétiques sont totalement différents
l'Allemagne c'était vraiment je veux
dire les énergies fossiles et en tout
cas les les bio enfin les notamment
toutes les énergies vertes renouvelables
le gaz aussi et en tout cas l'absence de
nucléaire ce qui était un choix
différent de la France donc on voit que
déjà entre ces deux pays on a du mal à
être d'accord sur une ligne d'un des
enfin énergétique donc moi je suis plus
circonspecte quant à la capacité de
l'Europe de parler d'une seule voix
parce que ça fait très longtemps qu'on
l'appelle de nos vœux mais le ministre
de l'énergie a quand même réussi à avoir
un accord sur les règlements afin de
diminuer de 15% et donc tout le monde
était d'accord sur ce point donc
l'Europe avance quand même malgré tout
même timidement et le je voulais revenir
sur les investissements la
énergétique implique une électrification
des
usages donc ça implique d'investir au
niveau de la production de l'électricité
selon je parlais tout à l'heure mais les
investissements concrètement alors les
énergies il y a les énergies
renouvelables mais les énergies
renouvelables ne peuvent pas régler tous
les problèmes comment fournir de
l'électricité quand il y a pas de vent
quand il y a pas de soleil et quand il
fait froid typiquement au mois de
décembre et on verra au mois de décembre
moi je le j'espère qu'on passera de Noël
de façon confortable et donc il est
absolument indispensable de mettre en
place une régulation qui permet de
favoriser des investissements sur du
nucléaire pour la France du nucléaire
qui permet de fournir de l'électricité
en base du gaz aussi parce que c'est le
gaz quand il y a des pointes on fait
tourner des centrales à gaz et puis
aussi des mettre en place des
incitations pour favoriser la
flexibilité de la consommation
électrique mais ça c'est tout un
chantier
je suis d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit et c'est vrai que je pense
que en fait cette crise effectivement a
révélé quand même qu'il y avait déjà des
faiblesses structurelles qui étaient
prêts existantes à la crise parce que on
voit bien que déjà même lors des hivers
précédents il y avait quand même des
problèmes sur la consommation
d'électricité de la France donc bon
voilà c'est un peu comme la covid ça met
en lumière ça a été aggravée par la
guerre en Ukraine oui ça a été aggravé
mais je vous dis il y a eu aussi des
problèmes préexistants et ça a révélé
certaines de nos fragilités donc je
pense que vraiment l'issue c'est c'est
pas uniquement de réagir à court terme
mais c'est vraiment de réagir à long
terme et j'espère que ça ne sera pas
juste voilà enfin que ça sera en tout
cas suivi suivi des faits et que les
actions seront menées pour qu'on arrive
vraiment à garantir notre indépendance
énergétique ce qui est quand même là on
l'a vu c'est quand même un bien de base
l'énergie merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
à tous les trois d'avoir été sur ce
plateau merci c'est la fin de ce débat
rester avec nous sur France 24
l'information continue